i heard a story one time that uh
guns and roses guns and roses open for
you guys and they try to party with you
and you guys drank them under the table
and you went out and did their set
dude no we didn't do their set um
uh they did try to out-drink us
and we were like oh [ __ ] here we go
again another band trying to [ __ ]
keep up with us this isn't gonna happen
so
we we went at it oh my god we went at it
right and
this slash will tell you this to this
day [ __ ]
we're like then they're just sitting
there it's slash and duff
and me and nikki were just [ __ ]
pounding shots at the bars like a
there's a day off at a hotel and they're
like
then you could clearly tell it was like
okay we're gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna out [ __ ] party you guys
and we're like all right
so we just [ __ ] keep going keep going
[ __ ] all of a sudden we're sitting
there and slash slashes starting to get
[ __ ] shitty
and he's just right at the bar at the
bar just right in between him and
duff just like
just blows chunks and he's like okay i'm
back
he's getting rid of it anyway he we keep
going we keep going we keep going
[ __ ]
it seems like a million shots later he's
he's that does one of these on the
[ __ ] bar
[Music]
and we go oh this is [ __ ] great
[ __ ] we
nikki and i grab him we take him [ __ ]
carry him up to his room his hotel room
keys in his pocket get it out open his
room
[ __ ] lay him down on on the bed face
up
right [ __ ] uh uh we
remember polaroid cameras yeah yeah [ __ ]
dude
we went and grabbed our polaroid camera
and mickey goes [ __ ] dude
get a picture of this nikki jumps up on
the bed pulls his
pants down and puts nikki puts his balls
right like right on right on slash's
chin
right there and i [ __ ] rip a polaroid
and the next day
that was his um uh our our
head of security went up and cut off his
[ __ ] uh
laminate uh all-access artist pass
and gave him the new one and the picture
the picture id was him it's him with
mickey's balls on his [ __ ] chin
i think we've made posters and put him
up everywhere that'll change a man dude
he's like
that'll [ __ ] teach you to think
you're gonna [ __ ] out party us dude
oh my god that was it i'm sure people
tried that all the time
all the time dude and you have probably
a thousand stories of just [ __ ] with
people
we're like [ __ ] amateur hour come on
you ain't gonna keep up with us yeah
dude